Today we will talk about diagnosis. Diagnosis is the identification of the fault
or faults responsible for a malfunctioning system. The system it could be a car,
a computer program, an organism, or
the economy. Diagnosis builds on our discussion of classification and
configuration. They start by defining diagnosis. They really setup two spaces.
A data spaces and a hypothesis space. Data about the malfunctioning system.
Hypothesis about the fault that can explain that malfunctioning system.
Then, we'll constructing mappings through data space to hypothesis space
which amount to diagnosis. We'll discuss two views of diagnosis,
diagnosis as classification and diagnosis as abduction. Abduction in
this context is a new term to you. We'll discuss it in more detail today.